[Music]
I'm picking it up picking it up picking
it up and putting the past behind her
ariana grande covering up another tattoo
dedicated to her ex Pete Davidson I mean
these two started dating back in June
and got engaged weeks after so they made
a few decisions when it comes to those
tattoos hey guys I'm 40 teza note joined
by Hallie Stevens it seems like ariana
grande is distancing herself from Pete
even more and of course the Internet did
not miss a beat
so after Ariana posted to her instant
story on Halloween fans noticed that she
covered up a matching reborn tag that
she got with Pete back in June okay so
we have a few questions guys we don't
know what the new ink is some are saying
it's a fern leaf others are saying it's
a feather let us know what do you think
now I'm kind of thinking it's a feather
but this isn't the first time the pop
star has tried to erase her past with
Pete while filming a very wicked
Halloween she covered her Pete hat on
her left ring finger with a band-aid oh
my goodness okay so my thing is how we
talked about tattoos the ones you
shouldn't get went unless you're married
so names couple tattoos all of those
things but why do we feel Ariana wants
to get rid of that new ink if they were
supposed to be hope for the future with
them you know it's kind of sad I do
think the lesson we can all take is just
don't do it I don't
don't ever get someone's tattoo like
don't just don't do it no couple tat but
a source did previously tell et that
quote they still haven't ruled out the
possibility of one day making their
relationship work I know when this all
went down they were saying that Pete was
heartbroken over the break-up and then
Ariana was the one to make the final
split so I mean she is taking things
into her own hands guys we want to dig
all into her reasoning why do you think
she's getting rid of these tattoos but
let's move on Seth Meyers weighed in on
Ariana and Pete split on watch what
happens live and he did not plead the
fifth
on a scale of 1 to 10 how shocked were
you by their breakup oh that's a good
question I mean I feel like I can answer
this I was shocked because I feel like a
couple that agrees to buy a pig together
right
has a deeper buy I mean again both
people in that relationship have to
think a pet pig is a good idea exactly
you would think that means you have a
lot of common with somebody that's true
okay so Seth does kind of have some
valid points and I loved it I mean you
don't buy a pig with someone unless
you're besties you know they seem like
best friends but we do know that
Ariana's had a really rough year
everyone knows that especially after Mac
Miller's death and a source had told us
when he died it was a huge impact on
Arianna and Pete was a huge support for
her as she coped yeah and seven weeks
after Mac died of a suspected overdose
he was honored at a celebration of life
concert in LA on Wednesday stars like
chance the rapper John Mayer Miguel
Travis Scott and more showed up to
remember the late rapper now we don't
think Arianna was there but she did post
a couple of videos with Max Dogg Myron
and this super-sweet picture of her
wearing Mac's hoodie and snuggling up
with his pup I mean it could all just be
a coincidence it could be her favorite
you know hoodie but a lot of signs are
pointing to the fact that ariana is just
not ready to move on or be in a
relationship right now we understand why
ariana is emotionally unavailable but
what do we think is there hope for
reconciliation in the future with Pete
and Ariana Courtney I'm gonna just go
ahead and say it I kind of don't think
so but we do want to know what you guys
think do you think she moved on too fast
after breaking up with Mack and maybe
was Pete more like a rebound
I don't know relationships are so sticky
I'm really hoping that it was not the
case they seemed to have a really good
relationship but all signs are pointing
to the latter let us know what you guys
think
keep let's keep the conversation going
on social media and until next time
we've got you covered on your pop
culture fix bye for now